Tại gần tháng 28 tháng 12, các bạn tính nắng lắt tổ chức họ báo thông tin vụ tay nạn
giờ thông xảy ra vào ngày 15 tháng 12, theo đó vào khoảng 12, 20 phút ngày 15,
là khoảng 12, các bạn tính nắng thông thông. Ông dễn quanh hàng, là cám vộ tần chả,
chảm kánh xác góc thông, cron vụ, đáng 20 trên tuyến đường cú bộ số 2 mi chính, thuộc địa
phản xá phân răng và xá kýpân tính nắng lắt, khi phát hiện một người điều kiện xa máy nình
gần có giấu hiệu bị phạm hành chính. Nhưng ông hoàn không thực hiện quy chính ra hiểu lệnh dương
phân thiện để kiểm tra, mà điều kiện xem một tô đặc trường của lực lượng cảnh xá góc thông
dùi theo phê sau khi đến bọn đường kí lúc mết số 1 chính tám cộng hai chăm cuối lộ hai mi chính,
thuộc gòn cứ ước sạch cựp tình đáng lắt, người điều kiện xem máy không làm chủ được tay lải và tông và
mừng thân nước về bên trái và từ vòng sau đó. Thì phát hiện xa bí tên nạn rau thông, ông hoàn với
vai trò là cánh vộ cảnh xá góc thông, nhưng ông đến vị chỉ xảy ra tay nạn để kiểm tra,
chú dúc mà quay xa đi về hướng người lại, thành vị có hoàn cấu thành tổ ở không chú dúc người đang ở trong tình trạng
của gì ở mẹ tính mạc.
Đây là vụ việc được trí lộn xá hội đặc biệt quan tâm trong những ngày qua,
khiến vụ việc đang được thử quan trức năng tiếp tục xử li theo cuy định của phá loại.